you fool which I always everybody loved
it so much I don't know I just think
it's the mentality of people that just
the people are awesome you know it's
just hard to explain I think each other
they're like you know there's people
that have lived in our states and move
to Cleveland Ohio and yeah you know I
get it now I see why you guys like you
guys are so like in-depth with each
other guys are awesome like you guys
love each other right yeah marry just
it's like its own nation it is weird
like Columbus in particular it's like
one of my favorite places to visit it's
like one of the it's it's like I get the
weather sucks a lot I get it but the
people are so damn nice like it's like
overall it's like a really good spot
yeah yeah I love Columbus I have a bunch
of blurry nights there down there I with
the brothers and all that good stuff but
I love Columbus - it's one we know the
one down there and crushing for like we
go down the Arnold and stuff like that
right checking it out you know the cool
anime fights and and our local shows -
we have like about our coaches go down
there for local shows remember when
these do the UFC with the Columbus with
the Arnold yeah there was a big event
there was a bit I wonder why that
stopped that was always a lot of fun one
time that strike force there it's when I
is it is a heavyweight champion the
world never been on a podcast before
I've been on a podcast like over the
phone but not like I'm still yeah yeah
so um but I think it was I Strikeforce
is when I Rousey and Kate fart and
that's okay - Rob oh yeah yeah I think I
think that was one of them yeah I think
so yeah back in the day so what's the
like walking around the UFC heavyweight
champ in the world
how's that feel that's good I'm like
fourth on the ladder it's my wife then
the two dogs and then me i'ma just pay
bills it feels like that sometimes right
there the money machine but so as
everything good now you or you finally
got a title fight you finally got a real
challenger and Francis
gah No On January 20th how do you feel
about this I think is a great fighter
you know definitely uh he brings it it's
hard you know but you know unfortunately
nothing's gonna change I'm walking out
with the ball still wrapped on the waist
I mean you know I'm excited for him you
know he's gonna shop but as long as I'm
here no one's gonna be champ damn if you
have to have that mentality what do you
think about him that's unusual
well like what what about him other than
the size and the strength what stands
out I mean its power I guess you know
but I think everyone is tired in the
heavyweight division I mean 260-pound
man 250-pound man I mean yeah you know
you know you're not supposed to be hit
by something like that and I know JD I
fought JD that's a far enough stuff on
my card I mean I got guys you know too
hard yeah you know and you know he just
thought he's a little wild too which is
that's tough you know sometimes you
can't prepare for that cuz there's
punches you don't see right - punchy
Alistar with a wild left hook yeah
things wide understand I think there's a
little bit of both on both ends yeah you
know we were just kind of you know
sloppy and then put his face right in
the lane and yeah Overeem's got a weird
style now right it's a it's a totally
different style over the last couple of
years you know but he does awkward stuff
you know like when you fought him what
did you how did you feel well when I
fought him he was like very traditional
moving around running but I kept gonna
keep his distance and like cool it's a
fight you know and then I you know he
tried that that lunging down Oh what
kind of cake to my thigh and I grabbed
it in time took him down but you know I
mean watched the whole fight with
maganda but I what I saw was he's doing
all these wild punches them yeah you
know when he fought me he's doing
straights and you know he was you know I
think within Ghana was almost like he
felt like he could not get hit which was
correct right so he just decided to be
just completely wild and unpredictable I
mean through that wild lunging left hand
to start the fight off and then got the
clinch immediately but wasn't able to do
anything with it
yeah yeah you know I'll find out Jamie
xx yeah I think all right but you know
are the best coaches in the world you
know I'm pretty confident walking there
you know he's big dude throws hard I
mean but that's every way yeah
take much well the only time we've seen
him on his back was uh which fight was
it taking that was credits played took
him down yeah
that was his first UFC fight right hmm
yeah that was an interesting fight right
you got a chance to see but it's it's
hard to see when a guy is really young
in MMA it's hard to see a fight from
three years ago or whatever that was and
then look at him and say well that's the
same guy today cuz it's not right yeah
yeah I mean I've definitely changed past
couple one thought for sure you know I
think you know he's definitely gotten
better there's no question um but you
know see what happens you know this I'm
glad they were broke you know I'm going
through a win you always do yeah now um
this is January 20th and right now what
it was it's December 13th or something
with
know about their fight oh no today yeah
so like how much time did you have to
prep for this wasn't prepping y'all been
working out I've been you know staying
in shape so did you have a feeling that
January was gonna be the card yeah so
when the UFC lets you know it but what
how do they how do they do that
how does it work usually contact my
managers like hey you know that's what
we're thinking
mm-hmm you know you be ready so you know
I was a little beat up after the the gds
fight you know with my shin and
everything not just my shin by other
things and just had to heal off it so I
took me awhile you know everyone thinks
I'm just trying to hold on to the belt
and just who the [ __ ] says that don't
respond yeah but uh you fought everybody
yeah it is where this we're gonna do I
can't make everyone happy but uh but
yeah I mean you know I was beat up a
little bit and just have a lot going on
and so you know now the